Fans and friends were clearly devastated to
hear about the death of "Power Rangers" actor
Jason David Frank.
Here's just a small sample of how they mourned
his passing on social media.
Jason David Frank's representative confirmed
to TMZ that the actor has died at age 49,
and is survived by his four children.
The news of the "Power Rangers" icon's death
has come as a shock to millions of fans around
the world, who tuned in over the last three
decades to see Frank's portrayal of Tommy Oliver.
The character first debuted as the Green Ranger
in "Mighty Morphin Power Rangers," the first
series in the "Power Rangers" franchise, in
1993.
Originally a villain under the spell of Rita
Repulsa, Oliver later joined the titular team,
deciding to use his powers for good.
"What have I done?"
"What you did, you did under Rita's influence.
You own the power now."
While his intentions were positive, the Green
Ranger was sometimes rebellious, causing friction
and clashing with his fellow Rangers.
The character later achieved legendary status
when he assumed the role of the mythical White
Ranger, becoming the formal leader of the
team.
Arguably the most popular and beloved "Power
Rangers" character of all time, audiences
were fascinated with how Frank added nuance
to an already tortured and multifaceted character.
It also helped that Oliver's Green Ranger
was the epitome of cool in the early '90s,
with young viewers obsessed with his charisma
and lone-wolf mentality.
After "Mighty Morphin Power Rangers" ended,
Frank returned more than a dozen times as
Tommy Oliver in spin-offs, becoming the anchor
character for the franchise.
He even had a small cameo in the 2017 live-action
film.
The star's final appearance as the beloved
Green Ranger was in 2018's "Power Rangers
Super Ninja Steel."
"Who better to destroy the real Tommy Oliver
than me?"
"Take your best shot."
Generations of "Power Rangers" fans have grown
up watching Frank as Tommy Oliver, making
the actor's loss all the more devastating.
As the news of Frank's passing made its way
throughout various pockets of the internet,
the "Power Rangers" fandom couldn't help but
emphasize and celebrate the actor's legacy.
One Twitter user wrote,
Echoing similar sentiments, another person
tweeted just how unique the character was,
pointing out how the Green Ranger was "a menace"
in his early appearances, causing new stresses
for the Power Rangers.
The fan continued,
Another fan tweeted,
Other users shared their grief by celebrating
his legacy.
One listed off all the many colors of Power
Ranger Tommy had been, tweeting,
On the "Power Rangers" fan subreddit, one
user couldn't quantify the impact the Green
Ranger had on popular culture, writing,
While fans continue to mourn the loss of the
beloved actor, those who worked with the Green
Ranger on "Mighty Morphin Power Rangers" also
took the opportunity to express their grief
and discuss Frank's legacy.
Walter Jones, who played the original Black
Ranger, told TMZ,
Amy Jo Johnson, who played the Pink Ranger
and Tommy Oliver's love interest, took to
Instagram to share a selfie of the two sat
at a fan convention.
She wrote,
Several celebrities from other corners of
the entertainment industry expressed their
sense of loss as well.
"Minions" screenwriter Brian Lynch tweeted,
"Evil Dead" icon Bruce Campbell also took
to Twitter to remember how he and Frank grew
close while on the convention circuit, writing,
"We enjoyed the crappy coffee, smoking stogies
on the loading dock and dressing up in whacky outfits.
Jason's loss is another reminder to appreciate
the ones you're with – right now."